welcome to the recruitment roller
coaster podcast my name is hisham azuz
and today i'm delighted i'm very excited
to have glenn walsh on the podcast and
glenn walsh is the founding director of
three recruitment businesses called
aspian the advocate group and more
recently milk education they have circle
40 people across these businesses
and have offices in liverpool manchester
and birmingham and um i think glenn's
probably one of the most passionate
people i've met in a while um when
talking about recruitment in this
industry so i'm super excited to have
you on glenn and thank you thank you for
joining me so where are you today again
i forgot you're right yeah that's right
no i live in a place called west kirby
which is on on the world so we um yeah
so we've got off wells in that area and
um yeah and luckily we've been catching
a bit of decent sunshine
so as i was saying to you before this
where
where i love to start on this podcast is
how did uh glenn walsh enter the world
of recruitment yes start there with that
story yeah good stuff so at the
beginning and then
look i think like a lot of recruiters i
completely fell into it
i think it was more of a locational
thing that happened to me so i was
living in carlisle after you leaving
university
um what'd you do uni so a sports science
degree okay i had zero impacts on my
career in any way she had performed
three years of getting drunk i know i
probably shouldn't say these things but
do you know what it was a great growing
up time it was a great time i left
university on the sunday started a job
on the monday really yeah absolutely
there was no in between look
my parents supported me as best they
could so i kind of knew when i left
university that i um i had zero choice
but to go and work and almost repair
that investment that they'd had
so um so yeah my personal lived in
carlisle so i moved up to carlisle um
enterprise rented car for six months but
i wanted to live in london it was as
simple as that oh really yeah i did yeah
i just thought to myself i want to test
myself in what i perceived to be the
biggest city in the world and um and i
had a lot of friends out there that i've
met at university so a friend of a
friend showed recruitment i took a week
off work came down to london met it's a
wreck to wreck firm um you did you think
you was did you think you was
interviewing for them
classic
i still couldn't quite get my head
around it right so
i still
what i couldn't i couldn't believe that
as an industry even existed but um
yeah and then interviewed with three
businesses a company called parker
bridge the currency and finance
recruiter um
oh gosh she's going back along harvey
nation bed knocking clark okay and um so
yeah the the idea of recruitment was it
was sales it was london let's go for it
so i literally i did that within five
days
went back up to carlisle handed him a
notice in on the monday three weeks
later moved down to london so i love
that literally straight in there what
what
what happened in london or you move into
london what what happened with that that
you didn't expect so clearly you had in
your head what you thought is going to
be like
but like because i went through that
process myself and it's definitely
taught me a lot and i'm it's one of the
best decisions i've made so far in my
short time on this earth so far but what
what just quickly like for you what
happened personally or professionally
that you didn't expect when moving to
london and doing that yeah look i think
the um
so my parents and friends lived in
carlisle i'm from bolton originally okay
the distance between the two is
absolutely yeah yeah for sure it isn't
you know i was quite unfortunate because
i had friends there however i moved into
a place called harold hill uh just in
just outside of romford okay and i ended
up getting the job uh just outside of
chancellor's uh chancellor lane tube
stage yeah yeah so that traveling time
of anything between an hour and hour and
ten minutes a day
was outrageous that's you know carol to
near manchester so that i did not fathom
i did not understand that so yeah yeah
i didn't enjoy that but i just think the
whole intensity with all i think the
whole intensity of london i created my
own intensity around it definitely
because there was an
overwhelming fear of failure really yeah
there was yeah i think that going back
to london but my ex-bossy how old was
you them don't literally 22 so straight
out of the universe
yeah so straight in there my xbox
enterprise rent-a-car when i hand him a
notice and laughed at me and just said
nothing
that's not going to work just so you
know
when things go wrong you can come back
i'm back yeah i thought all right okay
it was it was the worst thing
says to me i can't that's almost within
reason of course even more of a
challenge to do so so yeah i think the
whole intensity of london i think the
expense of it was
yeah yeah how long so how long do you
live in london for uh so i was in london
originally for
three and a half years looking around
and joined sent me to new zealand for 12
months really yeah which is a real
eye-opener i then and that was my
original path of setting up my own
business so i went to new zealand for 12
months run an office of 22 people built
some good money while i was there and
while i was over there i started on that
journey and thinking of okay could i do
this by myself yeah so probably a bit
too early if i'm honest with you if
you've had my time again i think the
idea you know that i had three and a
half years
so three and a half years okay
so just just quickly because i think yes
no no no it's good so okay that's
awesome so three and a half years so you
stayed that one company three and a half
years that's a real solid stint really
absolutely yeah okay and um just give me
a bit of context what market was it that
you were recruiting at that point i
would just start on temporary
accountancy and finance okay i kind of
got myself into a very good position
quite quickly the the the
director at the time put me in front of
wittily or not right in front of the
managing director's office so that's
learning a glass office
so that learning experience that almost
every single second of every single day
i thought to myself she was watching
what i was doing she's probably taking
no notice yeah but because of that was
an unbelievable learning experience
so
even if i did have that little bit of a
lazy genie which i didn't do i didn't
believe it did it kind of
how did you raise your standards people
make sure your standards are high
beyond levels that i didn't even believe
existed within me okay
so why why was it that glenn walsh got
the opportunity to go to new zealand
then because i think obviously there's
loads of
in the sort of over the recent months
six to 12 months you may or may not have
these conversations but loads of
recruitment businesses looking at the
american market and obviously more
recently that that may have changed or
how people are looking at it but i think
there's there's definitely
real opportunity and appetite for
recruiters to take their skill set
internationally if they want to which is
one of the coolest things about it right
but
i mean may or may not be in um i don't
know obviously what year this was may
have been slightly easier back then but
why was it that glenn walsh out of that
business got that opportunity yeah good
stuff so one of the reasons why i joined
the business is because they actually
had an australian new zealand office
okay university in the second year you
could do a
work experience so instead of doing work
experience in the uk i decided it's
gonna do work experience oh okay nice so
this was 1997 so yeah [ __ ] out yeah
i read your
long story short um we we printed off
yale.com in australia we were doing
sports science degree we i just we were
drunk one night i got on the phone at
two o'clock in the morning called lots
of different gyms
got three placements me and three of my
friends went over there i had a great
time another vision that i would go back
there um
so i joined the business because of that
but the reason why i got sent and the
reason why i end up opening up different
divisions within that company was purely
similar to this
because i was sat in front of the md's
office i overheard opportunities being
spoken about and i overheard one day
that the
director in um in new zealand was
considering coming back
so i then spent three days four days
writing a full business plan and writing
the reason why they should send me over
to go and do that it wasn't even on the
cards at the time but that then that
then pushed it quite hard they hadn't
considered that look i was going from
assistant manager i i said they had to
promote to me to director which of
course they didn't do they didn't
promote me at all they sent me to new
zealand
i was always looking for those
opportunities and very much on my desk i
was sniffing out the opportunities so if
i'm doing it in recruitment why
shouldn't i be doing it with my own
career and i think
that was the leading or that was the
major reason why they sent me um
where did that initiative come from
because i think it's come up a couple of
times now where i think
like for me um in in my career i worked
for a big insurance firm then joined a
small insurance firm had more direct
access to the ceo of that business and
that that transition experience just
really sort of made me think and my own
personal opinion was i would rather me
personally take opportunities in in
smaller ground businesses because of
what you're talking about there that you
have more direct access to the people
that actually own the business and you
can learn from these people and also
there'll be more opportunities so i
think but i think it's exactly what you
just said like you are you're looking um
on behalf of other people to progress
their career their opportunities so why
would i not do that for my own career i
think a lot of people in today's world
and want it to come to them or they do
they deliver a certain thing and they
think well why aren't they coming to me
and saying glenn you should be the
director of new zealand but actually in
these smaller growing businesses more
agile businesses you can walk into the
office and go
look i know we haven't spoken about this
before but i just taken it upon me to do
this business plan for the last four
days this is why you should consider me
like where did that initiative come from
because i think a lot of people can
benefit from that and really yeah really
good question max really good question
look you know if i'm going to get really
deep in it it clean would have to come
from some form of
parental drive to want to succeed you
know so the first person i called when i
when i got the job was my dad so there's
almost an element i've got it of course
um i played football to a a half decent
standard as a young man and i think that
that competitive edge and look if the
older i get the better i was if i could
replicate my drive know what i had or
what i've got no when i was 17 i think i
would have been very good at football or
a lot better than what i was yeah and i
think that ultimately
i think what happened i think i it
dawned on me very very quickly that i
was
not i can't sing like beyonce and i'm
not going to play for manchester united
so work would be my only choice about
bolton yeah or i don't know
and the worst thing is
i get ripped for that as well as but
you've got to follow your father
your father supports not that i'm a
glory hunter in any way shape or form
and i will spread my season tickets in a
second but i think look
yeah i think you dawned on me fairly
quickly that's why i went into work
straight away that yeah
actually
you've this is something i'm going to be
doing now for the rest of my life so i
need to do you really believe that yeah
do you know what a lot no not about
recruitments what i looked at is is that
so it was a conversation that my father
had with me and i watched my dad he was
just a fridge engineer one man banned so
there was a bit of a run your own
business mentality yes
um
he
i used to watch him come on from work
absolutely the tightest man i've ever
seen in my life i used to think i don't
want to look like that yeah well so i
wasn't fully bought into the idea but i
know when i left university and i was
coming down to london fear of failure i
have to ensure that this works in every
way shape or form yeah i have no choice
around it so then because of that and
because i don't know i never actually
ever thought i was just the norm i
always thought to myself that i was a
little bit different yeah i don't know i
was always sniffing out for what next
what next
well that what next mentality which i've
still got no i'll never stop
you know it's been said to me glenn
there might be a situation where you
know when you get to the end of your
life if you're always saying what next
will you ever achieve what you want i
don't give a damn as long as you enjoy
that sacrifice to try and get there yeah
because so yeah
yeah yeah i sniffed out the opportunity
but we were in an environment to allow
that as well yeah which obviously is
absolutely an important variable yes i
guess just to sort of round that off
before we start talking about
your journey as a business owner then um
i guess um
in terms of like
people that listening to this that want
those opportunities or
sort of advice that you give to people
in hindsight now of if they're listening
to this and yeah they do want to be the
person that you the business owner
thinks of first to consider giving this
opportunity or like what should people
be doing to give themselves the best
possible chance in the recruitment
business of progress in their career do
you think yeah what does your advice be
well it's something we've been
discussing internally within the
business at the moment but um
there wasn't anybody
unaware of what my
drive and outcomes were when i joined
parkour bridge
there was no question about it they knew
that i wanted to be the next md even at
21 years old
that wasn't it probably could probably
come across as arrogance to begin with
but they were i was i left nobody with
any doubt that what i was there for i
wasn't there for friendships and i was
still i got on well with people i was
there to a create as much money as i can
for myself but to not fail and to drive
my career forward because
and i never put it into this context but
you know i i kind of say it nowadays but
i almost turned it into my mindset being
and i never use the word mindset then
because it's a
but that was my manchester united so i'm
going to go in every single day i'm
going to give you my 100
and i think if you're doing that you're
always going to create opportunity even
if you work even if you do any job
the person who's working the hardest the
person who's willing to sacrifice and
just
do the [ __ ] that nobody else wants to
then
they tend to do quite well but the
awareness of our job means you're always
hunter gathering the awareness of the
questions that we say within our clients
you're always looking for that next new
thing
and
sorry if i've digressed slightly but
parker bridge we're always pushing you
to actually go and look at new markets
new avenues new ways
and i think yeah and i think they
inspired it with my absolute fear or
fear of failure
and willing to work as hard as i were
people yeah no that's awesome i
absolutely love that yeah so okay so in
new zealand then
the guy from bolton ended up in new
zealand
uh involving recruitment business
running running obviously teams so yeah
i understand why this sort of seed of or
hang on a minute i'm on the other side
of the world i'm running teams i'm
growing growing this business for parker
bridge
what would this look like sort of for
myself so just to help me understand and
then the people listening so this sort
of journey from you coming back from new
zealand then is that when you started
your the one of your recruitment
businesses or how what was that how did
it start yeah yeah good stuff so it
actually it started six months into new
zealand so it was the first time i got
any form of access to a p l
understanding of the finance side of
things i was working the currency in
finance anyway um
and i was billing very well i was
managing well um i can't again again
there was a circumstance to it my the
the business itself was going through a
management buyout and i was kind of
given put into a juxta or position where
are you gonna stay with us or are you
are you not
do you want to be part and part of this
mbo and then it kind of got me thinking
look i'm going to be part and parcel of
management buyouts do i i'm going to
have to commit to these guys but is that
really what i want
um
i think my real drive and hunger to go
and do something for myself kind of just
took over so six months into new zealand
and this is where i order was this is
2001 to 2002. i would leave work at
seven o'clock walk around the clock to
an internet cafe
into into an internet cafe and then i
was sending sense in between i don't
know seven to ten
working on the idea of building my own
business so the day i came back
is
48 hours later i was i resigned from a
job wow just out of so i'd already
planned it done it set it up ready to
roll it didn't go well but i'll talk
right now in a second but that that was
the plan okay so okay so just to help me
out then so as i said obviously as we
said in this intro glenn involved in
free recruitment businesses um so the
business that you started was it one of
those businesses then or was it yeah
okay yeah it wasn't so again
so briefly my idea was is that i wanted
to do with an individual that i trusted
an individual were you know
being by yourself in your living room in
london in a one-bedroom flight didn't
didn't sounded appealing because it
wasn't the dream but not the dream
so an individual was meant to be coming
joining uh setting this up with me and
12 weeks into the full ready to roll uh
he pulled out of me last minute oh wow
yeah so so it wasn't too bad i had to
then go out into the market and look i
found an individual um who was willing
to kind of joint venture with me the
financial services recruiter and i set
up an accountancy in finance division
originally then turned into a business
which was traded for about two and a
half years okay
so
yeah so i kind of had i wouldn't say an
easier route it was absolutely identical
to it um same investment type same money
in but i didn't know the individual and
that was that was the interesting side
of it yeah that was interesting yeah so
okay and then ju and then just to frame
out then so you had that experience two
and a half years
and then after that was it you started
the was it more the early business um
aspie and that was that was the original
one correct original one and then and
then obviously later on down the line
you start advocate group correct and
then more recently in milk education
that's right yeah that's right okay cool
because because i want to share that
because it has been uh it's been a
yeah it's been created over the past 10
15 years
why
why why more than one and why continue
to
sort of evolve and be involved with
other businesses why not just the one
recruitment business yeah but where's
this come from yeah good stuff well
when aspian originally set up um
it morphed into a financial services
recruiter
which is no no no it was counting
finances okay so it actually changed
slightly where this was finance
financial services sales
not only that specific specify or all i
say specializing in subprime lenders
so okay as we got into the late 2000s
saw 2007 2014 2008 and 2009 when there
was a market crash we went from having
300 exclusive vacancies to nothing
overnight
so black horse finance welcomed finance
which then stopped existing so a lot of
the subprime lenders they're our main
clients
so there was
a i can't i can't deny how tough that
was you know what did that teach you
that's important now wow you know where
did you even start and i think somebody
asked me something similar the other day
you know did you learn a lot of lessons
from that and i was like well yeah i'd
rather have read them in a book yeah
someone else experienced them but what
did it teach me i think
lean definitely without a shadow of a
doubt but business mix was the key thing
that went through my mind
not having all your eggs in one basket
basically yeah so all our eggs were
starting the financial services
sometimes
which hurts me so then almost we had to
start again again and then my main drive
was let's look at
almost relative market resistant because
it's just the pain and the money they're
lost relatively market resistant
industries
in 2012
you know it did you know it took a good
couple of years for aspirin just to get
back to reality look i was 1800 quid
away from losing everything i owned and
luckily one client paid me which kind of
got me through that one month which then
kept me in there but it went it it it
was difficult
i'm expecting it to be no different over
the coming months but we'll talk about
what did your life look like at that
point by the way just quickly because
yeah so that's that's
that's
that's a real situation to be in and and
some people might be in that situation
now so like what what did you just to
paint the picture so glenn yeah you
nearly lost everything as you said
did you have kids at that point did you
have a family do you have houses
absolutely house family cars
the the lot really 27 people in the
business so what night nothing what
where was your mind during that through
that do you know what i mean because i
think that that's that's the most that
will be the most um the biggest burden
for people right now yeah mentally what
like agree more do you know what i mean
because
yeah where where was your mind for that
and how did you push through that
obviously you got paid great but in that
moment
where was your head like what helped you
get through that do you think yeah good
stuff
look
i'll i'll say in a second what i wish i
hadn't have done okay because i did do a
i did do a lot of one thing which i'll
talk about in a second which i'm not
doing at the moment but what got me
through it was is that i laced my boots
every morning going to war that's how i
saw it in my mind yeah i saw it is that
i got up i did nothing else but get into
work and
i realized that i couldn't increase my
my brain capacity by the 40 50 that it
needed to be to get through it so the
only way that i could do that is
increase my work capacity so i just i
just worked longer i was i worked very
hard very long
trying to not panic
i was and it was uh it was tough i
worked saturday sundays i did anything
and everything that needed to be done i
turn myself into a credit controller i
turn myself into what i did everything
for my t credit controlled my finance
the the absolute lot to try and save and
save money but also in einstein with
that you know nobody nobody was exited
in the perspective nobody
everybody was treated fairly everybody
you know i kept a few with me um we had
to almost rip the business up and start
again within its markets to the point
where we ended up working within
self-employed commission only sales
people so actually one of my
testimonials i was reading the other
days on my linkedin was with the rac and
we were placing we come from placing
people
you know decent fees to
500 pound when they started and 500
pound a month down the line it was quite
tough but
we we we still started making money i
built a very good division so from a
mind point of view what i would do
differently is
i couldn't control the market where it
was there's
i'm a little small person in the market
and i spent too much time worrying about
it yeah and for every minute that i
spent worrying i wasn't planning an
action inc
so even when i look at it now from a
mindset point of view
yeah i'm analyzing yeah i'm looking at
what we can do but the only thing i can
control is action and action yeah yeah
it's all i can control i spent too much
time worrying about it look you don't
know your body and your brain's gonna
react do you you know did i spend
endless nights staring at the ceiling
thinking what the [ __ ] going on
hold the one yeah
i went to if you have anyone did you
have anyone you could speak to that
point no
and do you wish you had you wish you had
reached out to people yeah yeah i i
think my
my my name above the door mentality
which was probably led by eagle rather
than pride yeah probably forced me to
watch it maybe not search that person
and i had them available to me which was
worse
um
i think in einstein if i'd had a mentor
if i'd had someone who said glenn think
about it
you know channel stuff
my wife at the time who didn't really
understand um my parents didn't and
i didn't really have anybody around me
with access to money either so it wasn't
a matter of and by the way i tried oh
god yeah but everything got sold all
cars got sold everything that we could
do to make this work we made it work and
but i couldn't complain
he said i couldn't complain about it
because you can't complain when things
are going brilliant
and then
you know if things are going well then
you read the benefits of it if things go
wrong
isn't that the time when you actually be
a leader is expected to do more yeah
but it was tough it was yeah i think i
know i know you hear that advice
a lot but it's definitely helped me over
the last couple of weeks sort of
you've got to sort of catch yourself
when you're
ending up because you can so easily just
end up in the
sort of um wheel of
thinking and looking and focusing on
what you can't control yeah and you just
gotta get better at catching yourself at
doing that because it's so easily done
but when you really can when you really
do focus on
and realize that or do you focus on what
you can control it it generally you do
feel lighter
when you realize that well you come out
you've got some elements of success yeah
and we all know that feeling of doing
something gain a positive outcome
i think when you're so then if you're
actioning something even if it's just i
don't know whatever it may be
but sitting and worrying about it and
you can't control it and what's the part
of me lying
yeah
and then but and then yeah and i think
the final thing on that mate is
anyone listening that is struggling
right now honestly reach out for help
and then you will be surprising amount
of people that are willing to help
um
okay so that's really interesting and
then this has come up a few times
actually it was in one of the last
podcasts i did that right that sort of
experience actually then fueled
the thought process of all hanging them
in there i'm definitely gonna learn from
that and make sure and ensure that yeah
my eggs aren't all in one basket or one
particular vertical because if we do end
up going through some real adversity and
we don't want to be at the mercy of the
market where
everything could stop overnight yeah did
that that would obviously then obviously
you would go and say did that then fuel
that advocate group and other things
exactly what happened so the advocate
group specializes in fmcg so search and
selection um
into fmcg firms food and drink even
how do you identify that just out of
interest was it again
building relationships or using your
network to speak to people and you knew
people that
wanted to start a recruitment business
in the fmcg market they've done it and
then you were involved with them or
i
we we'd identified education and
manufacturing and fmcg
as the credit crunch was hitting so once
the turn was happening
i was just too slow you know being
honest with you if i'd done it six
months earlier it would have already
happened yeah
we so it was so
those two businesses conceptually were
already in my mind well if i look at you
know milk for argument's sake
eight years prior to me even setting the
business up i knew it was going to
happen
i just did it too late yeah so i had to
then put those to bed
build aspirin back up again yeah build
it to a point where it can start being
used from a cash code point of view
keeping my fingers crossed that the
market didn't dip down into a double
recession as such
and then so the advocate group actually
came about through the uh rejoining of
an individual who used to work for me
the recession um fortunately went
working within a manufacturing recruiter
that also specializes in fmcg so there
was a bit of luck there there absolutely
was we got a well chris and i we still
do
i trained in recruitment back in 2005.
um well i trade his skills you can't
train chris's attitude
he's just one of those guys though it's
almost he gets on the phone you are
listening to him he sits in front of you
yeah yeah i love that he's just he's
just an absolute fantastic character i
would like to say he was better that
he's better than me
yeah he is there he is there's no doubt
about it he's very very strong so
yeah he had a skill set
he had a bit of a knowledge base and we
set the advocate group up in very early
2012. once that was then set up and
running
the the only the next step for me would
have always been
education which is when it came about
yeah awesome
so okay so let's talk about i know
obviously we said before this that
you've obviously obviously you're
involved in all the businesses but i
know that you've been really actively
involved in in milk in in recent years
so i know you said that you obviously
agreed together that
people get most value out of talking
about that so let's just talk about that
for a second so milk's been going for
how long now
so original for four years but for the
first 12 months he didn't trade but i'll
i'll explain that um
because i had two other recruitment
businesses
this is the one business that i had a
bit of time to get to what in my opinion
was be to get right okay not that all my
experience has been leading up to this
one moment type thing but almost yes
so i thought look
let's research the market i've never
worked in education recruitment
never why did you identify that then
shooting because of market reasons so
one being um to give a bit more context
the advocate group and aspien are
predominantly perm recruiters yeah so
not only did i want a recruitment
business mix and have a temp market yeah
i also wanted one that was recession
proof credit crunch proof obviously i
didn't think about the pandemic crew
and
i suppose you can't think of everything
can you yeah yeah okay so
so that so that was the idea so that's
what we identified
plus we had an office in liverpool which
is what i was working out of at the time
and um you know liverpool a a um a
relatively insular market
um so the idea being if we can blueprint
it in liverpool and get it to work in
liverpool that i think we've got a good
chance of taking this into other major
cities throughout the uk yeah okay that
makes sense so that was the problem so
and then you said there the let's just
talk about so it took you 12 months to
like sort of what more the strategy and
thinking about how you're going to
execute and all these things yeah so i
guess
let's just think about for a second i
think
i'm sure you you've had different
conversations and people ask your advice
for help or whatever but i always say
this i think people are most worried and
most fearful of taking the leap taking
that jump yeah um and again think and
worry about that first year and
being in their living room or just
starting their own recruitment business
right so i guess
you absorbing all that experience
over a decade worth of experience at
aspien obviously advocate group
obviously you said it yourself it's now
right what what have i learned from that
that i'm going to make sure i do from
day one in this business so what were
the things that you made sure that
sort of that come out that strategy
period of the twelve months what did you
make sure that you did yeah absolutely
yeah in the
straight away
that's been in the advocate group
although we created a brand it was it
was an our brand was an afterthought
so it was almost i build a nick chris
building it we come on board we make
some money and then we'll talk about you
know consultants attraction and what
we're going to do client attraction and
we'll use our sales ability to to go and
win business first and foremost knowing
that i was never going to work as a
day-to-day consultant in the business
i wanted to create a brand that people
really bought into yeah
and if you haven't just saw it it's
about in there yeah
i'm just sorry it's a button but just
quickly
like if you were to go and definitely go
and check out milk education but i think
that's really cool you said that because
i think you definitely delivered on that
obviously we'll talk about it but i have
no idea how that's then impacted the
actual commercials in business but on
the face of it it looks it does look
awesome so that's pretty cool no no no
no i appreciate hearing that we've been
through four brand changes over the past
four years so we have just because not
that i'm a meddler but also in the same
respect i just think that if you're a
forward-thinking company shouldn't that
be reflected in everything that you do
yeah
and and the involvement yeah so the
first thing was brand first not not an
after four yeah so which is which is i
hadn't done before but i knew i had time
and i was lucky that i had time because
i had all the businesses which was
paying my wages so i think it allowed me
it allowed me to research the market i
knew i was entering a highly competitive
um
yeah highly competitive
tide recruitment market where new
schools are opening up every single day
so these individuals have already got
relationships it's already in place so
we have to have something which will
make them say
that sounds interesting
let me sample what you're offering
because otherwise you know
we would never break we'd never break
into them so the idea around the brand
was to almost
um
we are new we very new there's no grades
to this we're not going to sound like
we've been around for a long time we're
going to make it very very obvious that
you've never heard of us tweak a level
of interest and there's a lot more
context to it but that creation of the
brand
i wanted people to really buy into
whether you work for us with us or
whatever it may be
that was the i wanted that whole
rewarding element to us
how did you go about so was that the
main thing that you focused on was that
the main thing is going to help your
business be different and
yeah have a chance of okay
yes and no so yes is the answer but it
was then born out of what what was going
to be the differentiator you know i
think if i look back now at the uh
aspien
the differentiator was me because i was
going to get on the fallen cell yeah
where the advocate group was concerned
our differentiator was our market
knowledge you know the name brand
advocates to our clients but where milk
was concerned what is going to be the
differentiator and through my research
i realized that a lot of our
competitors a lot of our competitors
hadn't really taken the social media
side of things as serious as the markets
so what i wanted to do is to create a
brand in order to create a social media
presence in order to attract the
candidates above our competitors which
give us that selling edge yeah i love
that that's the idea so do
let me just ask you a really direct
question and then i'd love to sort of
dive into
how you've gone about that and your
learnings on that because i think
now even more so those people are
talking about it right so i guess
firstly
you deciding that and that being the
sort of forefront of your business
strategy
how is that
how has that then
um
impacted the business and you achieving
the goals that you set out to in terms
of taking up market share like how did
it actually help you yeah absolutely
well look i think first and foremost is
that because i didn't have the time to
train trainee consultants because i
never had the experience it's allowed me
to attract experienced recruiters okay
by direct competitors so first thing
helped you hire internally
absolutely
second thing is it it spawned
several key selling points which i said
in relation to our candidate attraction
which i didn't believe that any of our
competitors were doing to the level that
i wanted to and to give more detail to
that we're the most recommended
education recruiter in the uk on
facebook so whatever we do in these
rights yeah
i call them trust ticks
so with schools
like businesses but with schools if
you've been dealing with someone for 20
years
you know you to start using somebody
else you've got to feel like you would
want to trust them yeah yeah i think we
all think like that and we talk about
the word trust a lot within our business
of what whatever how does our
positioning evoke trust from that
individual because if they trust you
they're more likely to want to work with
you
so we wanted a brand that actually a
client may trust before they even speak
to us
so a lot of that came from throughout
research and i wanted something quirky
by the way because i didn't want
heritage it's definitely quirky yeah it
is
i think a lot of people don't back
themselves to do that and follow through
on being quirky a bit different yeah no
i agree and
it was difficult for me to be honest on
that premise because i was advocate
group strong you know high levels
especially from finance accountancy
background as well right yeah quite
stiff and we've always done it this way
absolutely
and the education market being very
similar to that yeah so i didn't want to
come across as though we you know we
were creating something gimmicky yeah
because i didn't want that but also if
you said to an individual no we've done
it to you know have a social media
presence yeah one of the big insights or
the the detail that we went into with
this was is that we wanted to again
evoke some form of positive response to
our brand before it happened so what we
wanted is the name of the business to to
to feel positive but also new at the
same time
so we looked at words from primary
school because my thought would be that
someone's more likely to have a positive
experience in primary school than
secondary school yeah a lot easier in
primary school isn't it
and what would him and then look to my
age demographics of the individuals that
i was selling to so the age demographics
that were people that we work with are
35 40 and above
so they wanted something that would
respond well to them
and make them feel quite positive so it
came from the actual old school
traditional milk bottles so it's
actually within our branding so yeah the
idea was is that i had them at school
and when i first saw it i thought you
know what i remember them so straight
away positive trust smiling so quite
marketing within his idea
and then we started to slip the idea
well look if the milk bottle represents
i don't know our traditional values
maybe the milk can represent a fresh
approach to recruitment so we kind of
coined that term and then and then use
that as a not quite positive marketing i
i know i think i think you're bang on
with that i think i think that and
clearly because you actually thought
about it instead of just went on google
and searched um creative words for other
knowledge and i mean just did that
scenario so i guess okay so let's just
sort of um
talk a bit about because because i think
it's safe to say glenn that a lot of
recruiters or people thinking about
starting their own recruitment business
will will agree with you that they do
want to build a brand that's trusted and
um different um and will will know and
want that to be part of their
differentiators as a recruitment
business yeah but and then i think it's
the execution that's really challenging
right so as you said you've gone the
brand's gone through a number of
iterations on how it's changed blah blah
blah but i guess
sort of real practical advice on then
actually it's a whole good thing you
thinking about in your living room and
doing all this plan but then yeah how
did you go about executing this thing
glenn like how did you really make sure
that
that translated into the people you
bought in and
yeah the brand actually delivered as to
what
the intention was unlike my first
business
i planned
yeah i know that sounds really really
simple another recruiter say all the
time make sure you plan before you go
home every single night when you walk in
with your plan this was actually the
first business because i wasn't
actioning a plan
i had to plan then for others and that's
a plan what that journey looked like
so the level of detail that i went to
you said the statements a second ago it
sounds like you really thought about it
okay
that is what our brand is actually meant
to speak and say it's irrelevant of the
name
my thought path is is that if someone's
going to be cynical about us which
they're going to be with a name like
milk then they're going to want to open
up things and turn things over and have
a good look at us and try and find any
form of cracks which is what people do
particularly when you're putting your
neck on the line calling yourself
something like milk
so i wanted every single facet of our
business to be thought about even down
to the point of the pens that we use in
the office which i know is a little bit
let's say quite detailed but they have
to be thought of something you know the
look on people to us was consultants
that was our main aim so is to attract
exceptional individuals to come and work
with us so the only way you can do that
is by creating exceptional environments
and if you saw you know our offices and
what we do it's um not quite 1990s where
we're playing table tennis although they
do have them in our we work offices but
how i executed it was just an absolute
i just had to back myself it was as
simple as that i'm i'm did you get help
from day one like did you get involved
in agency straight away or like how all
done in-house really yeah it was all
done in house it was all done with me we
had a creative sort of like copywriter
jack of all trades individual in the
business at that point in time we've got
a small team of two who've helped
massively on the rebound who've been
exceptional but they bought it they
understood it from day one but now when
it first started it literally came from
the passionate idea to have something
unique but have it been perceived as
unique from day one
i also didn't mind if people like milk
that sounds a bit stupid because i knew
that when they looked at us because we'd
thought about it so much then it might
make them think differently
so i think compared to what i did on the
first time the second time i think it
got a lot a little bit better with the
advocate group i think now where milk's
concerned if i went back to day one
would i spend that a little bit more
time thinking about and planning the
vision
you know thinking about our values and
um what it would mean to people i i i
didn't do that with any other business
bar milk
i've subsequently gone back and done it
but even the thought down to the point
of you know
people joined the business thinking they
were joining the underdog the underdog
mentality it was against the world um
we've kind of gone from underdogs we're
now trying to push towards that more
trailblazers are we doing something
different can we do something different
and trying to almost about that
mentality that i was involved with of
knock on my door
come set up a new division
new zealand oh i don't know could we go
to new zealand
why not try
hmm
okay so if i hold that answer yeah no
that does so just a bit of context then
yeah so
how many people do you have in the milk
business now obviously yeah good stuff
so
we've seen a lot of growth over the past
12 months so we went from four or five
people um
what that was what by year two uh by
yeah by year three
fourth year time that yeah there's about
25 involved in the business at the
moment and in the past 12 months we've
gone from liverpool with manchester
united
and
at the big end of mid to end of february
we also opened up a north wales office
which doesn't have its official opening
because of where we are at the moment
okay
cool so clearly then so the first so
nearly literally pretty much the first
three years
is a real solid core nucleus yeah and
then we've gone for it exponential
growth it seems like over the last 12
months obviously we're going to talk
about the sort of rough patch right now
and the challenges but i guess okay so
firstly um
how much then out of your let's say
overall
business budget or how much was you
investing in marketing
yeah i think because we were doing it in
in-house it's probably very difficult to
answer okay
however again because my time
yeah was not spent recruiting
and i think
i'll come on to that again in a bit more
deep but because my time wasn't spent
recruiting and i could invest time in
that brand
uh and the idea around it
um
okay so you put all your resources into
it okay yeah i did all right so
how so can i just jump back in there
yeah yeah you're going gone
but compared to the first business in
the second business
probably a hundred percent more time and
money and effort was put into it because
there was no
aspen there was no value within brand
and what we were doing begins with there
let's crack on
you know the group had a little bit more
thought around it and you know we
established a strong brand
and then
milk the whole branding idea but
a yeah it was that branding lifestyle
idea that you you you joining an entity
with a real passion and a real mission
a real will to make a difference
even to the point where we you know 18
months ago we turned the business into
an eco-friendly recruiter
but what does that mean i saw that yeah
good question so yeah so
our industry with the name like milk
we've got to be purposely different of
course and our industry it seems that
merchandise is definitely something that
they everybody will be giving to their
schools
so a key way to win business you go for
a client visit you take some form of
merchandise with me if the fact that
everybody else is doing it and it's kind
of seen that we have to as well as i
blatantly want to do it differently
in and around that time period
yeah
we did in schools i just think you've
got a
uh just in general i think there's a
corporate and social responsibility i
think yeah
i think you've got to do good things
well i genuinely do so i our whole we
started looking at the ideas of what are
we doing for charity what are we doing
around us we're dealing with with with
children so there's definitely a
humanity element
yeah i i've got well third and i've got
another dog coming so there's an animal
element i'll explain context to this um
one of them a rescue which is at another
rescue who's with us in in a few weeks
and um
and obviously the the call from the
elements so all our merchandise is
eco-friendly so every single bit of
merchandise then had a message yeah
giving it to schools we could talk about
plastic water bottles and talk about the
the use of single water you know single
plasma single-use plastics so we give us
a bit more context plus
yeah there's no real it just adds more
partnership and feel to what we do yeah
it gives us something else to speak to
schools about up and above
good recruitment
um we took that one step further
internally we have no plastic water
bottles in the office we you know little
things where everything's recycled from
a paper perspective you know we try our
best to reduce that carbon footprint as
much as we can in fact we've just come
up for a recruiter reward because of it
as well we've just been shortlisted yeah
that's awesome
so
my question was going to be and you're
sort of just talking about it there is
like so the vision the value the brands
really
sort of thought about things in detail
and as you said that's had a real impact
how do you then i think the challenge
that
recruitment businesses owners will have
or leaders in recruitment businesses
will then like how do you then
translate that into
or how do you then make sure that that
resonates and
is part of your people's dna i mean
there's all good things saying that and
you and you thinking about it's your
business yeah but how have you then made
sure that
you've you've instilled that
into the people within your falls and
your employees yeah even more so when
you're
opening up offices nationally like how
how do you make sure
how do you make yeah how do you actually
instill that into your people yeah good
question i think
i think it makes it easy based on the
kind of people who want to join us
because they're closed because of the
brand they're joining us that's
definitely a factor it is yeah because
they're looking at us thinking you know
what if i if i had all those key selling
points and that sort of positioning
and brought that to my schools
i'm going to win more business because
of that that was the key point part not
only that i'm going to generate a
competitive uh candidates above my
competitors
then that's going to make a difference
so that's that's so okay so the first
part is that people that actually wanted
to come into the business yeah one part
of the sort of motivation was glenn i've
been seeing what you guys have been
doing seems really interesting so that
okay that makes sense so you're already
yeah that already had
people's in in their mentality that this
could yeah this is why i want to join so
that helps absolutely
okay i think it also helps as well is
that i'm still massively i'm not being
arrogant here it's not all about me of
course but i'm still massively involved
in the business i'm there today i mean
you know i do
i'm a bit of an odd one who doesn't
sleep
enough um
even when i go down to birmingham it's a
two-hour drive but i'm getting there for
six o'clock so i'm getting in
ridiculously early working long hours
but
so when you say you're involved what
what's your your position i'm assuming
you're not on the phones or are you no
no no not in relation to a day-to-day
recruitment point of view but in
relation to trading
one-to-ones okay the development of the
interview so
so yeah so you can really ensure that
these people install the values that you
know are required to make milk is what
it needs to be to stand out
okay absolutely and look
it is more challenging when there's such
a distance you know from the world to
birmingham of course
you know but one of the things because
it's been within mindset from day one
that we don't want the brand to dilute
based on it's based on its growth seeing
that the brand is the thing that got us
there in the first place you know we've
been doing regular scenarios where we've
been we've been having group and
business catch-ups you know
group meetings in their own positioning
of the business um more recently cleared
with what's happened in the market we've
been doing a hell of a hell of a video
yeah very much so um
but i think the i think the appetite of
the individuals who work for the
business because the understanding of
the differentiator that it is has
certainly supported that but we're very
conscious of it we're very conscious and
we're you know the the brand values of
who we are um
people like them
how do you then
measure this how do you then measure
people
are acting in line with the values of
interest like do you do you do anything
interested on
like because obviously typically it's
glenn if you build this this is what you
get right but just out of interest then
if you really thought about this do you
do anything to reward and motivate your
employees in line with the values that
you have yeah good question so look our
our career development plan is based on
things like testimonials and better
recommendations from candidates and
clients you can't you can't get them
unless you're delivering our values
so even one of our one one of the parts
of it is that we've up something that
our first call agreements which we call
friends of milk
um
that is
the
the the exclusive agreement to work with
us it would be impossible to almost not
wait you call your exclusive agreement
friends of milk yeah
i love that so it's a little bit warmer
and i think that's what we've learned
through this as well as is that look
it's recruitment of course it says but
we've tried to humanize it as much as
possible you know in schools we're
dealing with kids we're dealing with
you know
i understand why there might be fear of
using another recruiter because well
what is their compliance like you know
do they work to dfe guidelines do they
do more i don't know i'll stick to what
i know which i get so we have to really
almost um
you know go and try and shake up that
market and look we know we're near there
we're not we know we're near where we
want to be of course we're not
but the instill of brand values yeah
look we
i believe that people should be promoted
based on on on delivering based on
outcomes yeah but also within that you
don't want someone let's say i don't
know
driving through your business who really
was some form of crazy maverick renegade
who did it their way and then yeah all
of a sudden you've got a team of
maverick renegades it could be quite
tough that way yeah so yeah
we're just even implementing something
at the moment were
well look
these guys
share the beliefs of the business
even if they even if some of them are a
little bit more not skeptical that's
probably the wrong word to use but it's
a it's a key selling point let me just
go out and sell to people anyway
the brand values and the family element
of what we've tried to to achieve
has brought a warmth to the company and
people do like that and i think schools
then like that warmth yeah people like
like doing business with us they enjoy
doing business with us
so
a real common um question uh
particularly more business leaders and
recruiting business owners send me is
hisham i'm at that four head mark five
head mark eight head mark can't get past
ten keep on a couple of people then back
to normal uh back to sort of original
numbers so i guess you can talk about
all three businesses and learnings but i
guess just really interested in that
sort of year of growth where people
really struggle to get those sorts of
numbers and of course
it's not all about head count which i'm
sure a lot of people will be learning
right now um yeah
yeah head count is vanity bottom line
sanity right we hear that a lot so i
guess
like how did you how did you approach
that i'm assuming you was in a good
position where you was really focusing
on
training development which helps but how
did you transition the business and how
did you achieve that
yeah a really good question look
that's the part where i would have to
say i probably made the most mistakes i
think the idea the mindset originally
was
bring on experience
that will push me through um which has
worked it has to apply experienced
education recruiters yeah experience
education or even within the advocate
group across the board we we've been
very much experienced recruiters it does
bring its own difficulties it absolutely
does what's the most common challenge
when you you've experienced and taken on
experiential credit i think when you're
bringing on a top performer who who and
it kind of goes against it but you're
bringing on top performers delivered
within the previous company and you've
got certain systems and processes that
also works very very well for yourself
trying to
mold that and manage that can be quite
difficult
because before you know it you've then
got an office
with people doing very different things
yeah and then that then you start
seeping away from the actual culture and
brand and engagement you've got
particularly then you start bringing on
you let's say more junior people yeah
what we didn't hit off of which we're
very close and this is what our next
steps are
i started with no recruitment experience
i started as a you know raw graduate i
think it's very difficult to replace
those first couple of years were you
willing to bleed out of your eyes to
make it work
but you are on you naively saw because
you just you throw everything at it and
um
you know i think if i had my time again
i would have
i want to do one or two things where
that's concerned so then i hope to
understand let's say people are going to
that growth
decide what you want first is this going
to be a a lifestyle business
or are you going to build this because
of xyz if it's lifestyle then just focus
on that lifestyle of getting them
getting to the level that you want to be
at and protect it
if you're going to build it into the
biggest business or whatever your your
personal goals are you've got to start
laying those foundations from day one
and that's got to be within training and
development that's something that i i
i'm not saying i've completely missed
out on it but we have used external
trainers um hannah keep being one of
them mike walmsley who i don't know if
you know mike michael ridge has trained
me in recruitment um so yeah look
so don't yeah it just come out last time
where don't have the mindset of i'll
invest in people like hannah and other
people when we get to 10 people
or it's got yeah you said later
yeah get it within your plan from day
one write that training program get you
know get training to almost be the
integral part of the development of your
business have we got that right i think
we've we've done it okay i think our
next big step is to get that so get that
perfect then we can attract those top
grads those individuals who would run
through walls like myself and train them
effectively um okay yeah yeah most
certainly yeah yeah okay that makes
sense and then i guess you just won't
come up to me because i was in a small
smaller business and
like if you're talking about grads and
attracting sort of people with not as
much experience or even on the
experience end as a small ground
business i think sometimes it can be
hard to think or hard to know how to
structure career progression yeah
because do you know what i mean you're
like well what else can i offer or
it's not the typical route of if you're
a bigger business do you know what i
mean so i guess
training development that you said it's
a part of that is you attracting people
that know
sort of where they are now and where
they can get to what they need to do so
i guess
what's what's career progression look
like and how have you structured that
for your people yeah good work and i
think
i get that's being difficult because
because how quick do you get someone to
start as a trainee to start billing very
well then the next step
did they become director within 18
months a year yeah you know
would you offer yeah yeah everybody can
be i think
we
so
milk spend a lot of time on the whole
um
personal goal setting
personal development um
what actually is going to get that
individual out to bed every single day
um
yeah there is a career development path
which i'll explain in a second but i
think the best
the best thing is to find out what does
someone want and if it's a
parachute or whatever it may be
if they've got that driver and willing
to sacrifice to get it let's hone in on
that in some way you know our our
extra you know we have a happiness
strategy within the business
where we we where we've looked at every
facet of what we do to try and make it
as comfortable
yet challenging of course because we're
in recruitment of god's sake but the job
makes you the industry makes it
challenging for you don't make your
environment challenging make your
environment brilliant to be in that
everybody wants to be in it and then let
the job put the pressure on
but to get there i think for anybody to
move up a path i think you've got to put
some form of stage gate billings they've
got to be performing
can't be any other place i think not
only have they got to be performing what
we do as well is also make sure that
they're performing through certain
criteria
and that criteria will be personal um
behavior patterns in other words pardon
my friends but they're not a [ __ ]
yeah and then the second side of things
making sure that the sticking to the
process that we've all agreed is the
ultimate process yeah so if someone it
triggers certain certain levels of
billings based over they've got to do it
over six or 12 month time periods
because i think you've got to restrict
that growth
to a point of course
let them then and we do you come and
present you show me now what have you
done to trigger not only hitting the
growth but to demonstrate that you can
do
sell retainers do this do this based on
outcomes i think that i don't
i think if you do it that way then i
don't think you're ever going to get
yourself where someone within a very
short period of time wants to take over
who wants to be the next director but
also show people the path to do
yeah sean the path yeah i think it's
what you just said mixed with what do
you want glenn yeah what's important to
you what do you want to have this
recruitment career yeah couldn't agree
more making sure you do that because and
then you and then you're equipped with
knowing what's put in place and knowing
what to motivate people with along with
the deliverables and the outcomes that
need to be measured yeah do not talk
about it once a year do not talk about
it once a quarter talk about it every
single monday on a catch-up
so i'll give you the prime example this
may come across a little bit harsh but i
have an individual in my business who is
actually our top biller um for aspie and
back end of 2018 when we broke down as a
review what you know what she'd done and
the outcomes of what she'd done it was
good but she was better than that a hell
of a lot better than that and nothing to
show for it so she devised god we want
to buy a house next year so we put
certain things into place were not only
did they expect to buy a house if she
didn't buy a house i would be reviewing
her employment within the business
he was a bit tongue in cheek but also
she knew i was dead the series not only
does she have to be top biller but that
extra level of incentive and we do
things we've got a mortgage advisor
company come in once every six months
two or three times a year anybody who
needs mortgage advice that's one of our
incentives we'll pay for that if you're
buying the house
so brent gives some form
there's no point spending a few years in
this industry and having nothing apart
from mental scars
uh probably a few nice suits and some
great holidays but yeah
no so
so we've looked at a number of little
things we've got saving schemes we've
got a financial advice company coming in
again giving
understanding of money how interest
rates work and et cetera et cetera which
should be taught at school in my opinion
but that's a completely separate
conversation but um yeah we spend a lot
of time on personal goals i would spend
more time on personal goals than kpis
okay
i love that
so
let's talk a bit about today then glenn
i mean you're in the education market
yeah
jesus
yeah
so i guess
let's just let's just put this stuff
that we can't control aside for a second
let's think about what you can control
right yeah how have you so firstly have
you have you had to follow
your staff or what what decisions have
you made on that front yeah across the
group we're about 60 40 um
so it's probably good to speak about the
group as well the advocate group hasn't
been
fully affected probably about twelve
percent
i mean i'm assuming
might be completely wrong but obviously
with yesterday's announcement saying if
you can't work from home go to work yeah
might open up even more opportunities
from the manufacturing standpoint and
stuff absolutely more certainly and look
we we were 10 11 days before shut down
happened already working for walmart it
was already happening looking through
our systems and ability excuse me we can
work from home
where milk's concerned yeah look we
didn't we we didn't sack anybody we
didn't get rid of anybody we um
we we we we panicked originally because
you know when it started happening
nobody was sure but again i used a bit
of an experience that i'd learned back
in 2008-2009
um
i think i put a post out on linkedin one
goals we all got so we kind of created
an internal siege mentality within the
business again that underdog
in this together type thing um
but we have seen we've seen a massive
drop in revenue there's no doubt about
it but we're confident that
schools will go back
yeah
okay so one of the most common things
that have come up from the live podcast
that i've been in and different things
has been
glenn how have you been keeping your
staff on furlough not on furlough yeah
motivated
yeah good question have you been doing
that
i won't show you the pictures i think my
um
fancy dress quiz which happened on
tonight was the starting point and i
won't show you the pictures but anyway
look we've had a
i'm looking that i've got a really good
team um
i think that
i can genuinely say and this isn't me
being heartfelt or selling it i'm proud
of them they've been
unbelievable across three businesses
there's been an insatiable appetite for
training there's been a
they are fully a workers have told them
that when we come over to this this is
the easy part right now let's be honest
with you when we come over to this we
are at war there's no doubt about it
this is going to be very difficult and
difficult how
i just think
there's three separate businesses let's
just focus on milk yeah yeah yeah nice
where milk's concerned is going to be
difficult pure and simply because we're
the new relatively new entrance to the
market although we
we're grabbing market share winning new
business could be quite difficult um
however
candidates are king they always have
been anyway our candidate care strategy
you know we send birthday cards we send
thank you cards we really you know we
try and roll out that celebrity service
all the time
the the recruitment consultancy with the
most candidates and the most
you know relevant candidates are the
ones who are going to make the most
money so why i think it's going to be
difficult is is that
there's a sharpening of the tools or the
sharpening of your of your weapons which
could be tough you know spend a couple
of months not doing anything
expecting them to walk back into the
game
match fit
i don't think that's going to be the
case i think that could be quite
difficult original over the first couple
of weeks
but i think it's going to be difficult
because
everybody's going to be leveraging
relationships and why wouldn't you be
doing
you'd want to leverage positive and
leverage every single relationship that
you've ever had
so i think the market's going to be
difficult because he's going to come
back with a
a bit of a bang and
competition is very very high anyway of
very well established businesses
more importantly if you're slipping
behind in relation to upgrading and
upskilling yourself and while your
competition is actually moving forward
that that could be the biggest difficult
thing
if we're not ready for this when these
doors and shutters open
it you know it does make you think
we're up against it anyway because we're
the new guys so could we make it easier
for ourselves by getting one step ahead
so have you have you started to
construct a return to work plan then
yeah yeah it's already started happening
so we've been bringing people off
furlough um almost in a slow staggered
way over the past two maybe three weeks
now
um
okay the idea being um
our
our candidate care strategy to to really
throw our arms back around and
get back to speaking to our candidates
for support reasons we were doing it
anyway but i wanted more people out
there doing it so there's a bit of a
risk involved in it but i don't think
there is i think people have
hopefully you know i think i think
you're right it was a someone submitting
the question
on the live podcast so we didn't know i
thought it was a great question it was
like there clearly is going to be a
scramble of talent there's going to be
way more talent on the market
there's gonna be talent a lot more
talent going directly there's gonna be
there's gonna be way more talent on the
market
and if you like what can you do
to ensure that you are the recruiter of
choice in the market this is this
exactly that we're talking about you
want to give yourself the best possible
chance of being glenda recruited the the
glenn is the recruit that i've been told
to speak to yeah and if you're not doing
anything to i don't know what what you
need to be thinking about because if
you're not you're naive i couldn't agree
more but you know is it is it the um is
it einstein's theory of insanity um
doing exactly the same thing and
expecting different results so i've seen
that it's no flip the opposite way the
market is so
crazily different then
why would we think doing the same thing
we'll we'll get different results i'll
get this even the same results so my
thought path being this yes i agree
there's going to be more talent on the
market
but i'm not too sure where schools are
concerned it was tight anyway
anybody you know
anybody near retirement age
probably based on on on you know the
not what the virus has been targeting
but who are more at risk might be least
likely to want to go back into an
environment where they could be yeah
that's true that's true yeah
schools are going to need more staff due
to the staggering
potential dinner times the staggering of
start times or the breaking down of
classes to enable some form of better
social distancing
so i think there's a there's a i want to
say a panic within schools but because
nobody quite knows exactly what's going
to happen at the moment however
yeah i think there's going to be
pressure from schools to be bringing on
more individuals to support
the the uncertainty of what's going to
happen next
um
okay so yeah it's going to be tough it's
good there's going to be a lot of people
not want to work within the market it's
got a lot of there's going to might be a
lot of people not wanting to go back
full stop yeah yeah
how how do you as we sort of come to the
end here then glenn how obviously you've
been in the recruiting industry for for
a good while so i guess yeah how how do
you see this in how do you see this
impact what's your sort of thought
process of
impacting the industry and your
competitors and just recruitment as a
whole how do you see this whole
experience and journey that we're all
going through impact the requirements
and look you know it's um
it's gonna i think it's gonna hit it
very hard i genuinely do you know if we
if we go back to 2008 2009 it was hit
hard however
i think if you're upskilling upgrading
consciously were
really pushing on the candidate side of
things and trying to to
get ahead now
i think you're going to be in a better
position
i don't i use this analogy and i don't
know it was the best analogy but you
know and i do see things about going
into battle and i've never been in the
army or anything but i do think see
things about going to battle and war but
i don't know
the weakest are more likely to die first
or exit the industry first so just
that's not you just make sure that
you've got you know you think about
every facet of the business um we will
bounce back the industry will bounce
back
there's no question about it i think as
a country we're very pragmatic within
our approach
who knows what's going to happen but
you know i think he's the greatest
industry in the world
i genuinely do i couldn't
i've got two kids one at 13 and one at
seven and if any of them end up working
in recruitment i'd be very proud i
really would i think that yeah but i
think also to get through this as well
i think you're gonna have to be a very
good recruiter and that's only gonna
also then spawn
you know an increase in excellence and
increase in standards i don't want that
let's have an increase in standard let's
hope it doesn't spawn people doing it
just for cheaper to just get through
doors let's just hope people you know
one of our big big pushes well is value
add what more can we bring to our
schools what more can we add how can we
support them even further to the point
where i'm even thinking about that from
a consultant point of view
so how is it going to affect us
i don't know i think it's going to be
tough i think if i was speaking to an
individual i'd be saying to them go and
train retrain go and find out what
you're very good at
recognize it and plan to do more of it
i love that
okay yeah last two questions what what
are you most excited about glenn to do
or have or experience post covered
what's excited about in what respect
just in profession professional
personally what are you most excited to
do come women come out of this yeah
do you know what i've missed the team
fella i am i missed it i've missed being
in the office i have i i i and and this
was what we even want to work for
somebody else as well as i love the i
love the recruitment office environments
yeah i think there's nothing more
exciting than walking through an office
where people are
making money from
a form yeah the computer and the
and the mines and i'm excited to be back
i am genuinely excited to be back with
the team so i think external of that
pubs restaurant but mainly getting back
into the office getting back into the
office seeing the guys and um
getting on it and taking this business
to the next step awesome
so the last question um you can answer
it with a phrase a word a sentence
whatever come comes to mind okay if
glenn could communicate to every single
recruiter out there they'd listen
they're taking their advice said
implement it tomorrow
what would you say to the people
a one word or a sentence whatever comes
from yeah it could be a sentence a word
or phrase yeah good stuff look
nobody likes working the long hours
nobody likes making the tough calls
nobody likes bd
turn that into your superpower literally
just embrace do the things that people
don't like doing and don't just do them
embrace them to the point like you are
playing for man united or you're the
next beyonce take control of it because
you're gonna probably be doing it for a
long time within your life so either
mourn about it or use that as your
strength
fully engage yourself into the industry
there's
committed
very committed extremely committed and
then
recruitment committed which is all the
way down here just give it that level of
commitment and i guarantee if you did
that over a time period
i think it's very difficult not to be
successful but you've got to give a
level of commitment that you don't even
think exists and just keep at it that's
what i'm saying i love that
glenn it's been an absolute pleasure
mate thank you very much